the jurogan experience let's start with
some sumo squats
not a big deal oh wow why didn't sumo
ever make it to america
because we don't we'd be we're fat we
like to wrestle
lazy
yeah
and they were all pissed about it he
became like the champion i think it was
a hawaiian guy that makes sense big
people giant big dude big polynesian
fella you seen the guy with the ukulele
yeah yeah one of them fell asleep yeah
he's fat big giant big bones big [ __ ]
frame yeah
you got to be a big [ __ ] they eat so
much you watch those uh sumo wrestlers
eat it's crazy oh really oh my god
because they that's the whole thing you
gotta have mass i think they get laid
like they're heroes yeah it's a in japan
it's a gigantic tradition i mean just
the the the rich history of it it's a
big deal over there
yeah that's gotta be fun though because
like over here you're trying to cut
weights it's always all about cutting
weight over there you're probably trying
to just keep gaining it also you're
wearing like this rope diaper that's why
i don't like the diapers that people
hang on to i love the diapers hang on to
someone's underwear and throw them
around by a very strange sport it is a
weird sport this is all wedgie
right i wonder if they've ever had
matches between like really elite high
level wrestlers that are big giant guys
and sumo guys like i wonder who wins
those if they do sumo i better love you
the sumo guys must dominate that they
know they know how to like it's just
linebacker [ __ ] right just going yeah it
was kind of like yeah but i would
imagine like a really good agile like
300 pound wrestler might be able to they
do have some of those they do have those
matches because there are some
uh sumo guys that are like smaller they
they look more like wrestlers they're
not big fat guys and they go up against
the yokozunos yeah because they've got
power boys what is that what is yokozuno
i don't know that's a great name yeah
yeah
right let's uh see like what is uh
that's like the mountain versus
who's the best
sumo wrestler today alive there we go
who's like the [ __ ] jon jones of sumo
wrestling there's got to be somebody
because jon jones the best
it's hard to argue
mighty mouse just won
the championship uh he won the rematch
and really got his title back yeah
mighty mouse is the [ __ ] man he also
put it on the line more than jon jones
well
i wouldn't say that i would say jon
jones put it on the line with everybody
that was against him in his division
yeah he likes the line that he had less
fights it's like who does jon jones
cleaned out his [ __ ] division you
can't say any fans or what's about it
but mighty mouse was less recognized
because he was small so these are the
best guys right now these guys are
throwing oh [ __ ] this is thin in america
oh don't even help the guy up no he's
like [ __ ] you bro
oh they're bleeding you never see the
bleeding oh wow smash heads wow is that
what it is yeah
oh yeah right he went nose to forehead
right there see this is awesome slap the
face we should do this here oh this is
crazy oh you're done dude you know what
you're doing oh it caught you slipping
boom wow
you land on the ground there's not even
a cushion there yeah why not make it
always even they're supposed to throw
you down like that's part of the thing
it's like the indignity of falling i
love it i love the diaper it's so
traditional
how hard can you slap i don't know last
nate no but this is what i'm saying like
otherwise
yeah look at that because otherwise oh
you're turning on the lady in the front
she shouldn't be there get out of there
with your phone
she was looking on her phone
her shoulder is probably [ __ ] up again
again
that lady's her shoulder must be [ __ ]
watch this boom
that's a man
look he's got a vault spot yeah you
don't want him
watch what happens to his shoulder no
more mayonnaise jars
you will never open up a mayonnaise jar
without harm bad ass yeah these guys are
huge giant they're not just big [ __ ]
they're like they're they're strong as
[ __ ] they're tanks who scores seven
trees the two bushes so these are the
best guys huh these are the best guys
they're not as big as i remember them as
a kid that's one guy no there's a big
guy there are big guys the best sumo of
all time
that fat guy is slick swim slick that's
what we call a swim technique i bet
they're slippery too those
asian hairless
cliffs
oh look at that he's like a seal they
probably aren't very specific just let
them go like you're probably not allowed
to grease your body no
shoulder right to the face oh
he knew he's dealing with a chump
we got to adopt this although you can
just see this as an easter egg yeah this
is just awesome that guy is like the
number two
two guys tails well he was definitely
beating him with strategy
now what do they make a year because
there got to be some diabetes and stuff
going it can't be good for you right no
to be that big
it can't be great for you i heard they
eat once a day
what jupiter crazy once a day to get the
metabolism down ten thousand look at
this guy ten thousand calories this guy
[ __ ] rules that springs seriously
that dude looks like he could take a
punch i want that outfit from there
literally look at his forehead oh
oh that was that forearm shot to the jaw
ko'd
i love the referee too oh my god that
dude is ko'd a hundred percent i didn't
know this happened wow i'm telling you
sumo is he gonna try again that's pretty
cool that i remember
here's slow-mo oh
his wow that should be illegal why not
it should be legal that's awesome i
thought it was just pushing it out yeah
elbows and [ __ ] it's your forearm maybe
it's okay to push with your forearm oh
that caught him with it that is
that's elbows look at these guys
i like how they're backstage is dingy
that's a special skill to hit people
with your elbows that guy moved
oh a nice flip there